Oh, Andy!
Oh my.
I can't tell
if that's a good "oh my word" or a bad.
[Nicole] Did you taste it?
Hold on.
- [record scratch]
- Yeah, I got it.
[all laugh]
[upbeat music playing]
- It is time to eat some good cake!
- Tell me more.
[Nicole] I found ten people
with dreams of being great bakers.
- [gasps]
- Oh shoot!
[all laugh]
In the end, the best baker
will get to learn key skills
and take home $100,000!
I have five daughters.
You know what I could do with 100 grand?
[Jacques] We have enlisted two coaches
to teach you everything you need to learn.
I don't know what to do!
- How's it going with these bakers?
- Ugh!
Some of them are just going haywire.
Looks like some of you are starting
to use buttercream on your cakes,
which Robert hasn't even demonstrated yet.
[woman] Oh no, Travis!
I got... Oh!
- Yeah, yeah. Just get me over with it.
- Angie!
- I ain't never done no cake like this.
- Go big.
I didn't know
we were sitting among Michelin chefs.
This is a huge improvement.
When you make something
from the heart, you feel the love from it.
I don't know if this is right,
but we're gonna double-fist the stirrin'.
If we pull this off...
You have learned so much.
[Nicole] ...someone might actually...
Whoa!
- Nailed it!
- [squeals]
We finally had good cake!
How did you get this job?
I'm really adorable.